[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émissionù nous
allons aborder un sujet bah qui
passionne les chefs d'entreprise mais
aussi les salariés c'est celui des
Ressources Humaines vous savez que dans
un un monde du travail qui est en pleine
évolution peut-être en pleine révolution
bah le monde des ressources humaines lui
aussi connaît beaucoup de changements et
on va en parler tout au long de cette
émission avec Anne Souillard bonjour
bonjour euh vous
êtes la présidente de de l'Association
des DRH des ivelines ANDRH ça s'appelle
l'association ex et et vous êtes la
dirigeante du cabinet RH humaniste et
vous avez organisé le le 10 octobre
dernier un un colloque sur le thème
partager pour réussir la transform
formation et la fonction des ressources
humaines alors c'est important on va en
reparler tout à l'heure mais c'est vrai
que vous vous rencontrez vous rencontrez
entre spécialist de ressources humaines
et vous nous direz pourquoi c'est c'est
important ces rencontres parce que c'est
vrai je disais c'est vrai que c'est un
domaine qui est en constante évolution
et peut-être même ébullition on va
parler dans quelques instants Pascal GOF
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le le
président fondateur de GoFast alors vous
faites pas du tout de trafic de drogue
he mais du tout du tout d'accélérer
effectivement les transformations
d'entreprise absolument et GoFast alors
c'est pas ce que vous appelez gofni
c'est c'est c'est le c'est le début de
de de votre nom oui c'est ça vous êtes
vous conseillez les entreprises sur les
les évolutions et et et vous nous
parlerez alors évidemment de de toutes
ces évolutions et notamment d'un sujet
qui est qui est assez fascinant c'est
l'arrivée de l'intelligence artificielle
dans les ressources humaines on se dit
les ressources humaines c'est un contact
purement humain mais l'intelligence
artificielle peut enfin aide déjà aux
Ressources Humaines vous direz voilà
quels sont les avantages quels sont
aussi les les limites euh Camille
Antoine Donzel bonjour bonjour vous êtes
aussi membre du du bureau de de
l'Association des NDR vous êtes avocat
associ du du cabinet litler c'est ça
exement et euh alors avec vous on va
plutôt aborder un une question qui est
aussi très importante pour les
entreprises mais aussi pour les
ressources humaines c'est celle de la
RSA RSE pardon la responsabilité
sociétale des des entreprises de RSA
c'est un peu autre chose
c'estement euh oui c'est aussi ça c'est
un thème assez récent la responsabilité
sociale des
entreprises en relation évidemment avec
avec toutes les questions
environnementales
euh pourquoi les d'ailleurs pourquoi les
entreprises se sont emparé de de de ce
domaine on va en parler tout à l'heure
mais alors pour plusieurs raisons alors
déjà premièrement c'est effectivement
c'est un thème qui qui devientent de
plus en plus preignant dans les
entreprises la RSE puisque c'est aussi
l'image l'image de marque de
l'entreprise on en parlera avec je pense
la marque employeur et parce que surtout
aujourd'hui vous avez c'est un sujet qui
va être de plus en plus régulé régulé
donc imposé aussi aux entreprises qui
plutôt que de se faire imposer des
mesures préfère les prendre en
anticipation et éventuellement les
développer et les déployer avant que ce
soit sanctionné on va dire et et vous
nous parlz aussi de bah justement de
l'application des ressources humaines
dans dans dans ce domaine et puis Émilie
Martin bonjour bonjour
vous êtes coprésidente de cette
association des DRH des ivelines enfin
qui est une association nationale là
c'est le c'est le le oui c'est groupe
local départemental et vous êtes la DRH
de d'entreprise qui s'appelle contr
contr transportation c'est ça tout à
fait qui est implanté sur 50 ans Eveline
voilà et qui qui fait quoi qui est
spécialisé dans les réseaux critiques
dans les Télécom principalement
appliqués au ferroviaires d'accord voilà
d'accord et euh alors un des thèmes que
vous avez abordé pendant ce colloque et
et dont on va reparler aujourd'hui c'est
celui de la marque
entrepriseur marqueemployur euh c'est
important c'est c'està dire que c'est
quoi c'est la un peu la la la l'image de
marque au fond des des entreprises he
exactement ouais c'est exactement ça
dans un marché du travail qui est un
peut plus tendu en ce moment
l'entreprise doit se montrer sous son
meilleur jour euh et donc à ce titre on
Doose vraiment une fonction marketing
très forte appliqué aux ressources
humaines ça veut dire quand vous dites
ça ça veut dire que au fond l'un des
principaux problèmes aujourd'hui des
entreprises c'est de c'est d'arriver à
trouver des des salariés qui
correspondent à à ce dont elle a besoin
c'est attiré en effet les les bons
profils oui oui oui oui dans il y a des
des profils vraiment pénuriques euh
aujourd'hui les candidats sont vraiment
maîtrre dans le on va dire dans la dans
la
relation pour trouver un emploi et donc
aujourd'hui les
entreprises doivent vraiment faire
preuve de d'authenticité et d'effort
pour attirer des candidats mais pas
seulement pour les fidéliser aussi pour
les fidéliser oui c'est ça
c'est vrai que bah oui il y a un marché
de l'emploi qui qui a qui a évolué aussi
depuis depuis quelques quelques années
c'est vrai que maintenant c'est plutôt
les entreprises qui recherchent
des des salariés Anne Souillard alors on
on va commencer peut-être par peut-être
nous dire quel qu'est-ce que c'est cette
association euh pourquoi pourquoi euh
ENF vous la présidez donc et en quoi
elle est essentielle pour peut-être se
regrouper pour parler entre soi de pas
rester chacun dans son dans sa sphère
voilà exactement donc ça s'adresse donc
au DRH aux fonctions RH de l'entreprise
ça permet vraiment de de mettre en avant
la fonction RH d'être en veille d'être
en veille de l'actualité RH ça nous
permet ça permet au DRH de se bah de se
retrouver autour
d'événements lié à leur fonction et
c'est de créer également de la valeur
pour les adhérents voilà donc c'est une
association qui s'appelle donc aage qui
a été crée en 1947 ah oui voilà donc oui
c'est et donc les ressources humaines ça
existe depuis juste l'près guerre
quooui et donc le bureau local Eveline
donc avec les du bureau on on développe
cette association au niveau local donc
sur le bassin versailla et de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline principalement
oui c'est là où il y a le plus grand
nombre d'entreprises voà et nous sommes
actuellement 70 adhérents h 70 donc
représentant la fonction RH et nous
retrouvons de manière la fréquence donc
mensuelle autour donc de soit de
petit-déjeuner sur l'actualité sociale
soit sur des événements par exemple là
donc on parle de l'événement du 10
octobre
impactant donc sur les enjeux RH 2030
mais également là dernièrement c'était
sur donc un
afterw mensuel sur la NAO la NA la
négociation obligatoire annuel annuel
obligatoire d'acord voilà donc c'est
l'évaluation ENF c'est ça non non c'est
lié avec le CSE en fait l'entreprise a
des obligations de de négocier des
accords et évidemment et alors ce qui
est intéressant c'est dire que vous avez
une entreprise indépendante hein de de
de ressources humaines oui pour ma parti
euh j'ai j'ai occupé la fauson de DRH
pendant plus de pendant une bonne
vingtaine d'années oui oui non non je
sais bien mais là là vous êtes votre m
émilie est dans une entreprise euh
Camille Antoine vous êtes avocat hein et
et et Pascal est chef d'entreprise ça
veut dire que ça au sein de cette
association ça regroupe aussi des
profils c'est différent voilà des
experts de la f exactement ou oui oui et
l'importance de ce justement de par
exemple ce cloc du 10 octobre sur les
qui est centré sur l'évolution justement
de la la fonction RH notamment
hein là aussi c'est des apports
d'expérience qui qui qui vous arriventou
oui et c'est pour répondre aussi parce
qu'en fait l'entreprise enfin la
l'entreprise se transforme de plus en
plus on va dire rapidement pour faire
face à de
nombreuses de nombreux enjeux hein tels
que la transition écologique tels que la
transformation tout ce qui est
digitalisation tout ce qui est nouveau
modes de travail et c'est vrai que B en
fait en en faisant intervenir voilà des
personnes dans ce domaineelà bah en fait
on se prépare vraiment de vraiment en
amont pour pouvoir bah aider aussi
également les les entreprises et les
salariés à faire face à ces
transformations justement
Émilie je je parle au deux qui exerce
des des fonctions de de de
DRH vous sentez une une évolution une
accélération même de de l'évolution de
cette fonction énorme énorme et tout le
monde l'a vu depuis la crise du covid
oui notamment le télétravail par
exemple donc le télétravail on est parti
dans le full télétravail et puis
maintenant les entreprises commencent à
faire marche arrière euh donc cela pose
énormément de
questions en terme de TER de RSE en
terme de contrat de travail enfin sur
différents plans on a l'intelligence
artificielle aussi qui est de plus en
plus présent en entreprise donc les
métiers se transformment et donc il faut
accompagner
anticiper pour pouvoir accompagner au
mieux les les entreprises h vous parlez
de de télétravail peut-être on peut
s'arrêter un petit instant
là-dessus c'est vrai que ça a été une
sorte de découverte avec pour beaucoup
de gens avec le avec la la crise de la
covid
et vous le disiez voilà et puis au début
ça a été c'est
formidable que tout le monde pouvait
travailler on rest chez
soi on on on revient un peu là-dessus
certaines entreprises reviennent en
effet sur sur le sur le présentiel parce
que il y a une réalité c'est que il faut
entretenir un lien social ou il y a une
unité dans l'entreprise et donc le but
pour entreprise c'est de trouver
l'harmonie le bon équilibre en fait
entre l'individualisation et le
collectif Pascal sur ce sujet justement
est-ce qu' est-ce qu'il y a des
différences entre les entreprises j'ai
l'impression que les entreprise enfin ça
dépend ça dépend des boîtes mais
peut-être
les plus plus récentes acceptent plus
facilement
le le télétravail que d'autres
effectivement il y a eu en je pense
qu'il y a eu plusieurs plusieurs choses
il y a il y a effectivement eu le besoin
de se mettre en télétvail pour toutes
les entreprises à un moment donné
pendant pendant la crise de la covid
voilà c'était devenu obligatoire et puis
et puis effectivement il y a aujourd'hui
ce retour lié je pense effectivement au
fait qu'on a besoin de lien social dans
l'entreprise après il y a des
entreprises qui le faisaient déjà
typiquement moi à l'époque j'étais dans
une entreprise où le télétravail n'a
rien changé puisque j'en faisais déjà
donc finalement au lieu de passer TR qu
jours par semain entreprise plutôt
récentes et modernes je dire c'est là où
c'est là où j'allais arriver c'est que
moi j'avais une entreprise ancienne mais
qui faisait déjà un peu de télétravail
et effectivement aujourd'hui les
nouvelles entreprises ont digitalisé
tout un tas de choses au sein de leur
entreprise et c'est vrai que c'est
beaucoup plus facile de faire du
télétravail et donc de T tréroyé de plus
la maison mais ça soulève quelques
questions quand même autour de la
sécurisation des informations de la
façon dont j'accède aux collaborateurs
et aux donnés de l'entreprise et autant
même peut-être de travail Camille
antoinez est-ce que ça ça par exemple
pour rester sur ce thème du télétravail
en droit du travail est-ce que ça change
aussi un peu les les choses alors ça
change les choses énormément puisque
déjà vous avez effectivement un
collectif de travail qui est éclaté ce
qui fait qu'en terme de management c'est
quand même beaucoup plus compliqué vous
avez aussi des sujets par rapport à tout
ce qui est accident du travail
puisque'avant l'accident du travail
c'était communément l'accident qui
intervenait dans l'entreprise sur le
lieu de travail et aujourd'hui vous AZ
des gens qui potentiellement peuvent
tomber dans leur escalier donc la
question c'est toujours est-ce que c'est
un acdent de travail ou est-ce que
c'était de la vie personnel euh et puis
effectivement derrière vous avez des
sujets de temps de travail de régulation
du temps de travail de suivi du temps de
travail qui est quand même beaucoup plus
compliqué quand vous avez des salariés
qui sont chez eux comment est-ce que
vous vous assurez qu'ils ont bien fait
la Hire de travail comment vous vous
assurez qu'ils sont pas en heure sup qu'
sont pas en dépassement lors duré
maximale de travail donc tout ça c'est
des sujets qui ont dû être appréhendés
par l'entreprise et qui d'ailleurs sont
toujours aujourd'hui en questionnement
parce qu'en fait d'un point de vue des
tribunaux et des des conseils de prudom
on n'est toujours pas encore très fixé
sur sur ce sujet ce sujet donc c'est oui
c'est ça c'est un des thèmes qui fait
que enfin des sujets qui fait qu'il y a
une grosse dévolution en effet du du
monde du travail il y en a d'aoutes on
va par parler alors de de de quatre
quatre thèmes justement la marque
employeur on va parler de la RSE on va
parler de d'intelligence artificielle et
puis on on conclura peut-être sur la
formation parce que c'est c'est c'est
essentiel évidemment c'est vrai que
avant avant d'aborder chacun de ces
dames un mot sur la formation quand même
il y a il y a une formation et et
peut-être que votre
association joue un rôle là-dessus une
sorte de formation continue nécessaire
pour les pour les DRH
effectivement
une veille est importante effectivement
pour exercer sa fonction voilà après en
terme de formation au niveau de
l'entreprise la formation FR est devenue
bah
effectivement un vecteur essentiel pour
développer les compétences des salariés
il être de plus en plus compétitif oui
d'accord ouais alors on on on reparler
aussi de de la formation tout à l'heure
on va commencer par le le premier thème
bah qui était un des thèmes que vous
avez abordé lors de ce colloque du du 10
octobre c'est celui de la marque
employeur làéie Martin vousvez avez
défini déjà un petit peu ce que c'est la
marqueyuse c'està dire c'est bah le fait
de au est-ce queon pourrait dire c'est
le fait de se vendre le mieux possible
oui c'est ça en fait pour
paraphraser la publicité d'un d'un
célèbre yaourt c'est c'est afficher à
l'extérieur ce qui se fait à l'intérieur
ou en fait c'est ça donc certes c'est
être un excellent communiquant beaucoup
communiqué mais comme on l'a dit la
marque employeur sert à attirer les
candidats mais aussi à fidéliser donc il
est fondamental de communiquer sur les
pratiques qui se font réellement en
entreprise sinon on va avoir un taux de
de de candidats qui intègrent une
entreprise et qui vont partir très
rapidement en fait et donc là ce sera un
échec donc c'est fondamental de
développer des pratiques en interne et
de les mettre en avant en communiquant à
l'ex d'illeurs ça veut dire qu'il faut
pas mentir non plus surtout pas surtout
pas surtout pas VO peut vendre faut pas
vendre ce qu'on a pas quoi tout à fait
il faut incarner il faut incarner ce que
ce que l'on communique à l'extérieur
c'est la clé et vous avez des exemples
par exemple bris d'entreprise comme ça
sur quel thème sur quel thème il faut
communiquer et et comment est-ce que
c'est les réseaux sociaux est-ce que
c'est les réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui
euh c'est c'est c'est un prérequis c'est
obligatoire euh parce que 95 % des
candidats pour postuler vont se
renseigner sur
l'entreprise dans laquelle il souhait
postuler et donc il faut trouver des
formations qui soient accessibles donc
il faut un site qui soit facilement
accessible qui soit
ergonomique il faut trouver beaucoup
d'informations sur l'entreise un
site un site internet un site internet
tout à fait avec idéalement ce qu'on
appelle une page carrière
c'est-à-dire afficher les différents les
différents postes à
pourvoir et puis également communiquer
sur les valeurs de l'entreprise sur les
pratiques de l'entreprise donc ça peut
être sur le développement du parcours
professionnel ça peut être sur la
formation ça peut être sur la RSE sur
vraiment tous les sujets et surtout la
marque
employeur n'est pas un sujet porté
uniquement par les ressources humaines
c'est un vrai pro d'entreprise qui est
soutenu par la direction et si je vous
écoute bien je me dis au fond le c'est
pas forcément le le salaire qui est
l'essentiel ça joue hement joue ça joue
forcément euh mais
euh ce n'est pas ce n'est pas l'unique
c'est pas l'unique critère voilà voilà
évidemment enfin chacun sait où il vaage
Audi les candidats ont besoin de sens
ils ont besoin de se sentir
ils ont besoin de se projeter donc il
faut pouvoir leur leur
offrir une vision une visibilité sur le
développement dans l'entreprise sur
comment ils peuvent contribuer dans
l'entreprise c'est fondamental est-ce
que je demande à tous he là-dessus
justement on a l'impression qu'il y a un
par rapport à alors je parle pas de ma
génération mais même les générations
plus plus jeunes que que enfin chez les
chez les nouveaux arrivants sur marché
du travail il y a un rapport au travail
qui est extrêmement différent de celui
qu'on a pu avoir dans des générations
plus âger vous vous avez ce sentiment là
non ou pas ou ouiètement oui hein il y a
une différence de génération on le voit
encore hein parce que on a on a des des
des salariés qui sont quin cas d'autres
qui arrivent sur le marché du travail
qui ont 25 ans et ils n'ont pas du tout
la mais pas du tout pas du tout ils
veulent ils sont en effet dans dans un
rapportant beaucoup plus plus rapide
tout tout doit être plus rapide en fait
euh on est dans un monde qui se qui
s'accélère mê complètement mais ils ont
besoin ils ont vraiment besoin de sens
c'est eux qui demandent vraiment le plus
de sens euh encore une fois tous ces
sujets de
d'écologie prennent de l'importance dans
l'entreprise et puis ils ont besoin eux
de voir au niveau individuel est-ce
qu'ils peuvent en retirer plus que plus
que
génération je voudrais pas faire de
généralité non non mais c'est vrai que
voilà il faut un accomplissement
personnel aussi dans le
travail alors que voilà oui peut-être
que pour des générations plus plus
ancien bah c'était une nécessité c'était
comme ça quoi oui il y avait plus
cettetion devoir en fait de devoir
accompli aujourd'hui non c'est vraiment
une quête de sens et un accomplissement
tout à fait par vous vous conseillez des
entreprises justement sur ce sur ce
thème là oui exactement moi j'accompagne
alors j'accompagne de deux façons la
première c'est que j'accompagne les
dirigeants qui sont pour la plupart
effectivement des gens de ma génération
on va dire qui ont pas eu cet accès ou
en tout cas qu'on qu'on qu'on créé leur
entreprise avec l'arrivée du digital et
qui doivent faire face à l'arrivée des
nouveaux entrants qui sont nés avec
alors né avec ne veut pas dire maîtriser
encore une fois je je bien préciser ce
ce terme là et puis effectivement je je
fais aussi des accompagnements et
notamment à HC qui est pas très loin
d'ici d'accord où jeisaccpagn des
prières années d' sur la quête de sens
justement c'est ce sont des élèves qui
sortent de classe préparatoire pour la
plart qui ont vécu et qui ont fait du
bachotage pendant plusieurs années pour
passer ce concours prestigieux et qui
qui arrivent en école et qui découvrent
finalement le le monde de l'école et moi
je leur apprends à à à mieux se
connaître pour être capable de savoir
quel est le métier qu'ils veulent faire
demain et comment ils veulent créer ce
métier qui à mon avis n'existe pas
forcément aujourd'hui oui il y a ça
aussi il y il y a aussi beaucoup de
métiers qui vont apparaître qu'on ne
connaît pas exactement et et c'est là où
on va sur ces sujets de quête de sang
c'estàdire que je leur apprends à à
mieux se connaître eux-mêmes pour être
capable demain effectivement de bah de
savoir quel métier ils ont envie de
faire quoi et cette quête de sens
effectivement elle est primordiale enfin
je pense que aujourd'hui de la même
façon que que que les les gens zappent
sur leur téléphone pour regarder tout un
tas de publicité ou de de chosesou
d'informations qui leur arrivent bah le
travail c'est un petit peu pareil ils
sont aussi capablebles de zapper dans le
sens bah voilà aujourd'hui ça me plaît
pas ben je passe à autre chose quoi
voilà c'est cette cette rapidité cette
cette envie de d'aller très vite et de
faire des choix pas forcément raisonnés
encore une fois je dis pas mais voilà de
zapper très vite ça c'est quelque chose
qui qui se voit souvent et ça vient
effectivement de cette envie d'avoir de
donner du sens à ce qu'on fait oui
maisard de cette importance de la
marqueyur parce que oui comme dit
pascalni on peut changer de boulot quoi
assez facilement hein aujourd'hui
d'abord il y a moins de problèmes pour
trouver des des des emplois déjà et et
et et chez peut-être une nouvelles
génération aussi il y a le fait d'
d'entreprise pendant très longtemps si
si on y trouve pas la satisfaction qu'on
qu'on y cherchait ça peut ça peut
arriver quoi c'est ça hein déjà pour
postuler le candidat est un vrai
consommateur il doit pouvoir postuler à
une offre d'emploi aussi rapidement
qu'il achète quelque chose sur Internet
d'un clic en un clic il doit pouvoir
postuler euh donc ça c'est la première
chose et après en effet il faut vraiment
faire très attention à l'intégration à
l'onboarding des salariés les les 6
premiers mois sont fondamentaux euh pour
pour les nouveaux embauchés
l'intégration pour exactement euh
l'intégration avec les équipes dans
l'emploi mais également dans dans
l'univers de l'entreprise
euh pour pouvoir s'inscrire dans la
durée étant donné que en effet c'est
vrai que les nouvelles générations vont
être plus promptes à zapper si euh bon
je vais voir mon là il y a quelque chose
alors ça aussi c'est aussi une
spécificité des nouvelles générations
c'est qu'ils vont plus facilement
communiquer ce qui ne leur convient pas
nor dire les chos donc le manager il
fait al alors qu'avant gens peut-être
n'osait pas enfin tout à fait ou ouis il
prenit plus sur ça veut dire en filigran
dire que que justement les ressources
humaines prennent une importance
primordiale parce que c'est c'est ça
savoir c'est réussir le mariage en effet
avec les différentes tout à fait c'est
ça c'est soutenir énormément les
managers dans leur dans leur quotidien
c'est aider l'entreprise en effet à ça à
se montrer sous son meilleur jour et
puis c'est un peu comme l'huile dans le
moteur hein pour pour fluidifier les les
relations dans l'entreprise c'est un
facilitateur les ressources humaines
sont des facilitateur j'avais lu alors
je sais pas si l'enquête est vrai ou pas
mais que
euh le le burnout est est très fréquent
chez les chez les Raches
enfin et c'est vrai euh c'est alors en
effet on a eu des chiffres même je plus
en tête mais c'était assez inquiétant
même enfin étant ouais ouais c'est aux
alentours de 70
%h ouais ouais ouais bah je pense que la
crise du covid a été très
les directions les salariés se sont
vraiment reposés sur les ressources
humaines pour traverser cette crise qui
était
unique et donc ça c'est une première
chose donc il la fatigue accumulée et
puis c'est vrai que les ressources
humaines les personnes qui qui se
dirigent vers les ressources humaines
sont des personnes qui veulent qui sont
tourné vers l'humain bien s et il faut à
la fois satisfaire l'entreprise la
direction et les salariés oui on est
pris donc on est pris en é on est pris
en ÉAU et il peut y avoir en effet cette
difficulté de de d'avoir de l'impact
d'avoir du de montrer son impact dans
l'entreprise en effet par rapport aux
autres fonctions opérationnelles de
l'entreprise mais mais justement ce de
malêtre enfin difficultés parce qu'on
pourrait penser comme ça à priori oui
quand on doit
licencier des des des des gens on
comprend enfin mais ça n'est pas que
dans ces dans dans cette sphère là hein
que que non c'est au quotidien parce que
quand vous avez pour mission de
d'accompagner une une d'accompagner la
transformation d'une organisation il y a
il y a différents intérêts qui qui
rentrent en conflit et donc c'est
compliqué ça peut être difficile de de
de trouver la la cohérence et
d'harmoniser en fait tout tous ces tous
ces éléments conflictuels en fait euh
donc et puis surtout les ressources
humaines sont là pour tous les salariés
oui absolument ou voilà euh et et donc
il porte aussi tous les euh tous les
tous les soucis on va dire des salariés
c'est c'est le rôle HM donc après c'est
qui s'occupe des RH donc c'est pour ça
que l'association des des ressources
humaines la ndrh euh a cet objet c'est
de lutter contre la solitude des RH de
partager sur les bonnes pratiques et
s'entraider et ça c'est c'est
fondamental vous avez beaucoup un soy de
de témoignages comme ça de de au sein de
l'association enfin sur sur parfois les
difficultés de leur tâche quoi en fait
effectivement on a de ils ont même si
dans la plus dans l'association ils sont
tous heureux
mais évidemment évidemment non mais ils
ont c'est vrai qu'on a ils ont vraiment
une volonté de ben en fait effectivement
de rompre ce sentiment d'isolement et
c'est vrai que en venant
partager sur leur pratique sur leur
quotidien c'est vrai que l'association
répond
vraiment à ces demandes oui de plus en
plus en effet le fait de pouvoir parler
de pouvoir de savoir que d'autres sont
dans la même situation que vous ça ça
évidemment ça ça aide c'est plus en plus
oui c'est important d'échanger entre
pères ouais sur ces problématique du
quotidien ouais et Camille Antoine no
droit du travail enfin du travail vous
avez enfin peut-être au Prom enfin et
des des beaucoup de de de de
RH de RH alors non fort heureusement
parce que moi c'est plutôt les gens avec
qui je travaille au cotidien en revanche
non mais il demande beaucoup de conseils
là-dessus al euh oui al il demande
beaucoup de conseil parce que les RH
aujourd'hui comme disait Émilie c'est un
peu la la zone tampon entre la direction
et les salariés donc comme vous le
disiez ils sont pris en étau entre les
deux ils doivent satisfaire l'intérêt de
l'entreprise et l'intérêt des salariés
et puis tout en gérant effectivement
leurs obligations et leurs contraintes
qui soient qu'elles soient juridique
réglementairire ou même politique
parfois euh nous on le voit en tant
qu'avocat de toute façon puisque souvent
on dit que les avocats sont stressés
mais en fait le rôle de l'Avocat aussi
c'est d'absorber un peu le stress de son
client de dire à son client alors moi en
l'occurrence mes clients ce sont des des
DRH des RRH leur dire bon bah voilà on
va je travailler avec vous main dans la
main et puis on va essayer de de gérer
une situation ensemble et donc nous on a
aussi comme rôle de catalyser un peu
cette cette pression et de la prendre
pour nous aussi voilà après les DRH sont
pas des gens qui sont des gens ce sont
des gens qui qui voilà qui ont un peu
l'entreprise chevillé au corps donc on
les voit pas très souvent prudhom c'est
des gens qui sont plutôt voilà qui qui
ont cette finesse parfois de dire voà
par d'viter exactement donc même eux
n'ont pas ce réflexe pour eux de voilà
de de finir en freedom en revanche ce
qui est vrai c'est qu'effectivement voà
il y a une grosse pression et et la
crise covid a beaucoup beaucoup impacté
les RH puisqueeffectivement moi j'en ai
vu beaucoup qui d'ailleurs ont changé de
métier j'en ai connu quelquess qui m'ont
dit moi j'arrête parce que c'est trop
compliqué cette période covid a été très
complexe à gérer il y a eu beaucoup de
de sujets notamment avec l'activité
partielle je sais pas si le chômage
partiel qui a été un vrai sujet très
compliqué que ce soit en RH ou en paye
et donc c'est vrai que ça unu
Paris malêtre de r après voilà moi for
heureusement je suis pas encore le
psychologue des RH mais voilà en tout
cas effectivement je constate moi dans
mon métier que qu'ils ont leur pression
et que j'essaie moi de la prendre un peu
avec eux et parce qu' vous parliez des
des nouveaux salari ENF des entrant des
élèves d' CHC mais il y a aussi des
entreprises que vous conseillez
justement le la question des RH c'est
une question qui revient souvent alors
ce qui revient souvent en en fonction de
la taille des entreprises que je
conseille justement c'est c'est assez
par x c'est que c'est souvent une une
fonction qui est négligée dans le sens
où elle arrive très tard dans la
constitution même de l'entreprise
c'estàd qu'une entreprise va attendre
d'atindre 20 30 40 salariés avant de se
préoccuper de la fonction RH le
dirigeant se sentant légitime on va dire
quelque part pour le faire et ce qui est
pas forcément le cas tout le temps c'est
ce que j'allais dire c'est que c'est
souvent malheureusement pas le cas et et
c'est donc c'est ce qui explique aussi
que les petites entreprises ou même les
start-ups on on un turnover dans les
employés qui est énorme parce queah
parce qu'il se préoccupe plus du métier
des affaires de l'entreprise que des
salariés et donc le bah la contrepartie
c'est que les salariés vont viennent et
comme ils ont l'habitude de zapper ben
maintenant voilà c'est devenu c'est
devenu juste un moment de passage quoi
et les dirigeants de plus en plus
aujourd'hui se tournent alors je sais
pas si quelque chose qu'on abordera mais
se tourne vers des DRH partagés parce
qu'effectivement engager un DRH bah
c'est c'est c'est quelque part un coup
parce que c'est pas quelqu'un qui
produit pour l'entreprise donc ça
devient un coût et ce coût aujourd'hui
ben il pour les petites entreprises qui
vous voit la nécessité d'avoir des RH
disent ben je vais faire du RH partagé
donc je vais m'adresser à des bureaux
qui font du RH pour X entreprises et qui
vont m'aider bah pour gérer mes salariés
pour gérer mes fiches mes fiches de paye
pour gérer mes contrats et cetera et
cetera et ça c'est ce que je vois
régulièrement dans les petites
entreprises que j'accompagne après dans
les grandes entreprises que j'accompagne
la fonction RH enfin je pense qu'elle
est intégrée maintenant dans les
entreprises globalement enfin c'est
devenu c'est devenu quelque chose qui
vous diriez deune façon générale enfin à
partir de combien de salaries il vaut
mieux alors même si même si c'est un RH
partagé euh il vaut mieux faire Rael à
alors je dirais j'ai pas de chiffres et
puis je me vois mal prononcer un chiffre
mais mais ce que je vois des des des des
dirigeants que j'accompagne on va dire
jusqu'à jusqu'à 10 15 salariés on est
sur du RH partagé au-delà quand on
commence à atteindre les 20 50 salariés
on commence à avoir des des RH qui sont
voilà des RH qui sont vraiment installés
dans l'entreprise et puis et au-delà
effectivement là on a des services RH
qui s'installent avec effectivement
plusieurs personnes qui ont des
fonctions bien particulières dans
l'entreprise enfin formation recrutement
et cetera là on on commence à
effectivement silotter on va dire la
fonction RH Martin ça ça revient enfin
ce que Pascal c'est c'est vrai que bah
justement dans cette marque employeur le
le rôle des r essentiel justement parce
que c'est l'accompagnement c'est le
enfin là pourrait pas faire 100che
presque sur cette sur ce sujet là c'est
un coordinateur
voil
finalement toutes les bonnes pratiques
de l'entreprise et en effet il est le
premier concerné parce que il est chargé
de recruter donc le RH a conscience en
effet de l'importance de cette marque
employur mais qui joue aussi vis-à-vis
des clients oui oui bien sûr c'est une
question de not il y a les clients
extérieur aussi bien sûr bien sûr même
les fournisseurs aussi dans les dans les
différents partenariats donc finalement
c'est tout
l'écosystème économique qui est impacté
par la réputation c'est quand on entend
les les Ch d'entreprises notamment
nouvelles entreprises c'est vrai que
l'un de leur problème c'est comment se
faire
connaître et et et sur quel point il
faut insister quelle est la spécificité
quelle est la l'identité des entreprises
c'est c'est ça qui c'est ça aussi la
marque employé c'est ça ouais ouais
complètement alors il est clair que
certaines entreprises bénéficient déjà
d'une notoriété
internationale je parle pas des mais
quand on se lance sur le
marchéentreprise lance il est clair que
comme on disait tout à l'heure il faut
vraiment développer les réseaux sociaux
ou ce lesquel le LinkedIn oh LinkedIn
c'est c'est c'est vraiment ouais tout à
fait après tout dépend si on est B2B si
on est B2C à quelle cible on on
s'adresse donc ça c'est pour les réseaux
sociaux mais vous avez aussi donc le
site internet ça c'est un impondérable
et puis après il y a tous les réseaux
professionnels qui est qui est important
pour développer les bonnes pratiques
pour se faire
connaître au niveau
local faut vraiment les forums les
salons qui sont organisés voilà il faut
savoir ce que disent les spécialistes
des réseaux sociaux raconter une
histoire aussi hein il a enfin
s'impliquer dans dans dans dans C dans
cette communication nouvelle quoi ouais
ouais tout à fait faut vraiment
réfléchir on est vraiment dans une
stratégie de de social médiia
c'est-à-dire quel quel discours on veut
tenir quelle histoire on veut raconter
en fait à notreou est voilà tout à fait
quelle histoire on est le
oui le tenor
enfin Anne sou justement on parlera de
formation tout à l'heure mais c'est vrai
que la formation au réseaux sociaux pour
les RH c'est c'est c'est très important
aujourd'hui c'est également
incontournable voilà c'est c'est
incournable oui complètement et je à ce
que disait Pascal parce que vous avez
une une société qui qui fait des RH pour
plusieurs entreprises he c'est ça oui
euh vous vous conseillez plutôt des des
des PME des des des petites moyennes
entreprises ou ou il y a aussi des
grandes entreprises qui n'ont pas de DRH
dédié non non c'est en fait
effectivement on travaille avec des PME
et des ETI principalement ouais ouais et
à partir de combien de salariés c'est à
partir de 25 personnes à peu près euh
combien vous dites à partir de 20 25
personnesis souvent oui ah oui oui oui
même avant hein un petit peu oui ou
c'est un contournable ouais complètement
ouais et si sinon oui c'est ça sinon bah
pour tous les problèmes qu'on qu'on va
qu'on va aborder c'est vrai que c'est
c'est compliqué à à régler et puis pour
la
gestion l'objectif aussi de croissance
de l'entreprise donc effectivement on a
on accompagne enfin un DRH à temps
partagé et et est présent par exemple à
partir de 10 salariés si l'entreprise
par exemple souhaite croître et souhait
attendre par exemple un effectif de de
50 voire 100 dans les 2 ans 3 ans à
venir là effectivement le DRH déjà le RH
interne enfin le RH à temp partagé déjà
à l'origine va travailler déjà et va
accompagner le dirigeant sur sur cette
stratégie là pour atteindre bah ces ses
effectifs par le recrutement voilà com
finiser après en interne comment
développer la formation et cetera plein
de leviers à mettre
effectivement alors euh on va peut-être
passer à un autre thème important euh
avec vous comm Antoine Donzel c'est bah
c'est justement la la Responsabilité
Sociétale des Entreprises
[Musique]
exactement alors RSE développement
durable et ressources humaines voilà
c'était c'était le thème je crois d'une
des tables rondes
euh alors oui je je vous repose la
question que je un peu posé tout à
l'heure mais c'est bien d'y revenir en
quoi c'est
important alors d'abord qu'est-ce que
c'est alors ce comprendre c'est que la
RSE et c'est un peu comme tous les
thèmes qu'on dont on parle aujourd'hui
c'est c'est un thème qui n'est pas un
thème uniquement RH c'est un thème
d'entreprise auquel le RH devient partie
prenante et d'ailleurs vous regardez
aujourd'hui la plupart des RH s'appelle
business partire parce qu'en fait le RH
participe du business de l'entreprise et
le business de l'entreprise passe
notamment par la RSE la RSE c'est un
thème qui est assez vaste et ça serait
compliqué de le le définir en une phrase
voire un mot euh mais c'est c'est
finalement c'est effectivement
l'environnement c'est un peu le
comminément c'est ce qu'on entend
développement durable et environnement
sur ces sujets- là donc vous avez tout
un voilà toute une politique
d'entreprise qui va se mettre en œuvre
alors par différents Biers moi de ce que
j'envois par exemple sur le juridique
vous avez des aspects sur le
développement et l'environnement qui
vont prendre le la forme par exemple
dans le cadre du du dialogue social
pardon avec les représentants du
personnel aujourd'hui vous avez dans les
entreprises qu'on appelle la bdse qui
est la base de données économiques et
social et qui est devenu la base de
données économiques et sociale et
environnemental et donc aujourd'hui
l'entreprise doit communiquer auprès de
ses représentants du personnel donc les
CSE sur les données environnementales de
l'entreprise ça c'est un sujet qui a été
intégré par la loi climat et qui
aujourd'hui donc met fait un pas en
avant sur le juridique sur l'intégration
de l'environnement dans le dialogue
social vous avez également aussi cette
même loi qui a imposé aux entreprises
notamment dans le cadre des
réorganisations de consulter le CSE sur
les conséquences environnmentementales
des projets c'est-à-dire que je vous
prends un exemple vous prenez un site
industriel que vous déplacez d'une zone
A à une zone B il faut que vous indiquer
au-delà des aspects euh de de ressources
humaines de l'entreprise l'impact
environnemental du projet CS donc il
faut les consulter donc prendre leur
avis là-dessus donc ça c'est un premier
sujet ensuite la RSE c'est un peu plus
large que l'environnement c'est
également on peut dire la qualité de vie
au travail ou la qualité de vie des
conditions de travail euh aujourd'hui
par exemple vous avez des sujets qui
sont prignant en entreprise qui sont des
sujets de harcèlement moral ou sexuel
mais très souvent moral et ça c'est des
sujets qui doivent être appréhendés par
les entreprises dans le cadre de la RSE
puisqueeffectivement vous avez
l'obligation en tant qu'employeur
d'assurer la sécurité de vos salariés et
cette sécurité elle passe notamment par
le bien-être et le bien-être bien
évidemment suppose de pas être harcelé
quotidiennement au travail donc ces
sujets là vous avez par exemple ça peut
prendre la forme aujourd'hui de
dispositif d'alerte professionnelle qui
permettent au salariés de signaler à la
direction des sujets de harcèlement avec
des enquêtes derrière qui vont être mis
en place dans l'entreprise avec ou sans
les représentants du personnel mais très
souvent avec d'ailleurs vous avez
aujourd'hui dans les CSE ce qu'on
appelle des des référents harcèlement
dans les entreprises d'une certaine
taille qui permettent au salariés
effectivement problème récurrent c'est
problème qui est de plus en plus
récurrent alors qui est récurrent de par
le fait que ça arrive et que voilà les
relations de travail sont parfois un peu
tendu dans le contexte un peu tendu bah
le harcèlement alors après le
harcèlement est toujours aussi parfois
une question de de ressenti mais
n'empêche qu'il faut quand même un peu
dérouler le fil et voir un peu ce qui se
passe est-ce qu'on est sur un management
qui un management un peu autoritaire ou
un véritable harcèlement et et puis
derrière vous avez ces sujets quand même
qui viiennent de plus en plus prignants
pour des raisons aussi alors peut-être
un peu plus financière parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez dans les
licenciements des barêes d'indemnisation
qui ne sont pas applicables dès lors que
vous démontrez avoir été harcelé donc
vous avez aussi ce sujet qui vient
nourir malheureusement aussi harcèlement
parfois bon voilà et vous avez aussi des
sujets après qui sont un peu plus
heureux quand même moi j'ai l'exemple
d'une entreprise un grand groupe
international qui avait travaillé sur la
mise en place d'un dispositif de mutuel
et de prévoyance
pour l'entièreté de ces effectifs
c'estàd dans le monde entier vous avz
10000 salariés qui avent été couverts en
frais de santé en mutuelle et en
prévoyance alors ce qui était en France
assez commun mais dans des pays beaucoup
moins bien disants en termes sociaux
c'était une vraie révolution et donc ça
ça avait été finalement une des voilà un
dispositif qui a été mis en place dans
le cadre de la
rsreise et et toutes les toutes les
entreprises sont concerné on parlait
tout à l'heure de de petites moyenes
entreprises très très concrètement
toutes les entreprises peuvent être
concernées maintenant ce qui est sûr
c'est que les grandes entreprises euh ne
peuvent pas ne pas saisir de sujet les
plus petites voilà et d'ailleurs ça
participe je pense de la marque
employeur c'est de dire bah on affiche
nous entreprise euh une politique de RSE
une politique qui soit une politique
dynamique de RSE et qui permet
d'ailleurs alors effectivement d'attirer
des talents et d'attirer des jeunes qui
veulent du sens dans le monde du travail
également de fidéliser les gens euh donc
oui les entreprises sont toutes
concernées euh maintenant euh peut-être
toutes ne vont pas s'en saisir
immédiatement puisque ça peut être aussi
la RSE au début en tout cas bah des
coûts pour une entreprise mettre en
place une politique c'est aussi de RSE
ça peut être des coûpt et en fonction de
la taille de l'entreprise et de ses
moyens on n'a pas toujours les moyens de
le faire mais en tout cas c'est un sujet
qui théoriquement concerne toutes les
entreprises et toutes les organisations
parce là aussi en tant que conseil de
d'entreprise c'est un sujet qui qui
revient ou c'est exactement ce que je
vois mais effectivement dans une moindre
mesure en fonction de la taille de
l'entreprise encore une fois il il y a
les grandes entreprises qui n'ont pas
d'autre choix que de le faire parce que
en plus elles sont elles sont visibles
on dire quelque part et puis a les
petites entreprises qui le font mais
elles elles le font plus effectivement
pour attirer justement des des des
talents et des gens qu'elles ne trouvent
pas sur le marché assez facilement et
donc effectivement elle mett en avant
certain nombre de choses alors moi ce
que je vois essentiellement c'est autour
essentiellement de l'environnement parce
que c'est un sujet qui aujourd'hui est
très d'actualité et donc c'est sur ce
sujet de l'environnement de du bien-être
au travail que que les petites
entreprises travaillent voilà c'est ça
mais effectivement ne l'affiche pas
aussi bien que peuvent le faire des
grosses entreprises donc par contre là
où je le vois c'est sur la
l'accompagnement c'est vrai que
l'accompagnement au RSE c'est quelque
chose qui est pas forcément fait dans
les toutes petites entreprises c'estàd
que c'est à un moment donné c'est
quelqu'un qui son qui se saisit du sujet
dans l'entreprise et qui essaie faire de
faire en sorte que ce sujet murisse au
sein de l'entreprise mais c'est pas
forcément facile voilà puis qu''il y a
d'autres impératif quand on a une petite
entreprise on a des impératifs qui sont
beaucoup plus économiques que RSE
effectivement bien sûr et justement
est-ce que c'est d'une façon générale
c'est considéré comme une chance ou
comme une
contrainte ça dépend des la direction
c'est que j'is dire très bonne question
très bonne question oua ça dépend oui ça
dépend de je dirais que ça dépend de la
sensibilité des dirigeants encore une
fois c'est il faut pas oublier que
quelle que soit la taille de
l'entreprise celui qui est le
responsable de l'entreprise ça reste le
dirigeant de l'entreprise enfin le ou
les dirigant d'entreprise finalement
c'est eux qui insuivent ou pas la
volonté de s'inscrire dans une démarche
RSE plus ou moins forte plus ou moins
visible et et voilà il y a pas de il y a
pas de bonne réponse finalement à cette
questionl quoi c'est c'est ça ne dépend
que des dirigeants et de leur volonté
voilà c'est ce que ce que vous montriez
d'ailleurs très bien c'est que au fond
c'est la définition de la RSE c'est très
vaste euh ça ça ça peut aller en effet
des préoccupations environnementales de
de l'entreprise jusqu'au bien-être des
des des salariés et c'est c'est très
vaste et surtout alors c'est c'est assez
complexe à gérer puisque dans est-ce que
c'est pas trop vaste justement alors f
pas alors je je je prendrai pas la
responsabilité de dire que c'est trop
vaste parce qu'on va me dire que je suis
pas
RS non non mais mais toujours est-il que
non mais dans la pratique vous vous enz
c'est par beaucoup de choses ce qui est
intéressant d'ailleurs c'est que ça peut
permettre à des entreprises en fonction
de des moyens qui peuvent allouer à ça
de prendre des mesures qui sont des
mesures qui participent de la RSE sans
pour autantf voilà en tout cas en
pouvant le faire avec leur moyens après
le sujet de la RSE ce qui est toujours
assez compliqué c'est que vous êtes un
peu sur le fil de rasoir c'est-à-dire
queà la fois c'est une politique que
vous allez essayer d'avoir assez
dynamique dans l'entreprise et de
l'autre vous savez il y a toutes ces ces
sujets de green washing on va vous dire
mais finalement c'est de la RSE
d'affichage mais derrière voilà derrière
vous faites rien donc c'est toujours ce
sujet là aussi c'est il faut communiquer
donc on rien peut-être à la marque
employur tout ça mais derrière il faut
que les gens VO des choses concrètes il
faut soit concret parce que c'est pas
concret on va dire bon vous avez fait un
super site internet un super compte
LinkedIn avec de la RSE mais derrière il
y a rien qui a été mis en place donc
voilà ouiie c'est vrai c'est la barque
employeur et la RSE encore une fois faut
incarner le discours oui c'est ça et
c'est et
c'est puisque vous parliez justement des
des des nouveaux salariés enfin des gens
qui arrivent dans les entreprises c'est
quelque chose qui tient probablement à
cœur non des de plus en plus des gens
qui qui de plus en plus et d'ailleurs on
voit dans les nouvelles générations des
nouveaux entrepreneurs qui se lancent de
plus en plus dans les entreprises à
mission donc qui qui qui dépasse même le
stade de la
RSE et qui intègre dans leur statut
vraiment la mission de leur entreprise
euh au niveau humain sociétal
environnemental et ça ça se développe de
plus en plus développe de plus en plus
sur ce
sujet non sur le sujet de la RSE
justement en tant que en tant que bah
conseillère de de d'entreprise euh c'est
un sujet qui revient sur justement sur
les on parler des petits tmoyens
d'entreprise c'est intéressant làdus
parce que ça rentre effectivement dans
la marque dans les actions de d'une
d'une marque employeur donc en fait
c'est d'accompagner on dire les
dirigeants sur par exemple bah comment
mettre en place des actions concrètes en
TER mais c'est quoi qu'est-ce que je
déjà ou et surtout de mettre en place
des actions concrètes qu'est-ce que la
RSE et en quoi ça consiste comment je
peux la développer en dans mon
entreprise oui c'est ça parce que à
priori enfin il y a des ça ça ça
concerne des entreprises qui qui ont des
activités extrêmement différentes au
fond hein et et puisque et comme comme
vous le disiez puisque après tout le le
le domaine est très vaste donc on peut
toujours trouver un fil à tirer quoi
ouais mais c'est mais c'est important
c'est ce que vous disez enfin c'est ça
c'est c'est c'est aussi important pour
les nouveaux arrivants et voilà hein ça
fait parti et même ceux qui sont là
depuis longtemps et non non bien sûr non
non mais bien mais là là aussi il y a
peut-être non mais je voulais dire par
là il y a peut-être aussi euh un petit
gap générationnel non disons que les
mentalités ont évolué euh donc c'est
vrai que c'est peut-être plus remarqué
chez les nouvelles générations parce que
comme on l'a dit ils sont plus spontanés
et ils communiquent beaucoup plus leurs
attentes euh mais même les générations
plus plus anciennes sont de plus en plus
sensibles à h t CJ alors on va parler
d'un autre sujet euh mais qui qui est
alors qui peut être étonnant comme ça
c'est l'arrivée de l'intelligence
artificielle dans dans les ressources
humaines c'est c'est notre 3è
[Musique]
thème PASC gofti alors euh c'est vrai
que euh on peut être étonné hein par ce
ce mélange entre justement bah ce qu'il
y a des moteur de recherche et puis et
puis puisque est une matière très
humaine mais au
fond l'arrivée de des outils
informatique elle est elle est
relativement ancienne oui elle est très
très ancienne même puisque on parlait
déjà d'intelligence artificielle dans
les années 30 40 avec ce que je ououi je
je l'évoque assez souvent c'est le le
fameux test de Turing qui est un test
qui a été inventé dans les années 40 50
qui était justement l'idée c'était de
dire qu'est-ce qu'une intelligence
artificielle et le test de Turing c'est
si jamais je ne suis pas capable sur un
test de différencier si c'est un humain
ou une machine qui me répond je suis
face à une intelligence artificielle
c'est ça la définition on va dire de
base de l'intelligence artificielle d'
on pe on peut toujours la la garder
aujourd'hui ou cette déf moi j'ai
tendance à penser que oui après ça c'est
mon avis personnel je pense que oui
parce qu'effectivement même si
aujourd'hui on parle d'intelligence
artificielle sur sur la production
d'images sur la production de texte et
cetera il suffit de s'y pencher un petit
peu et on arrive à détecter un certain
nombre de choses qui laissent à penser
que ça peut pas être un être humain qui
a écrit ça ou c'est pas un être humain
qui a produit cette image et cetera il y
il y a des signaux quand même qu'on
qu'on découvre assez facilement mais
c'est vrai qu'on reconnaitt assez vite
le style de chat GPT par exemple bah
peut-être je sais pas non non oui oui
non mais quand on est habitué quand on
travaille dedans moi c'est assez facile
de mon côté parce que je je travaille
avec assez régulièrement donc je détecte
un certain nombre de signaux qui me
laissent à penser que c'est un texte ou
c'est une image qui a été produite par
une nia maintenant c'est vrai que on va
dire le commun des mortels c'est un peu
plus compliqué parce que bah parce que
on est très vite pris par Ben ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure par la l'affluence
de l'information l'affluence des images
et cetera et on se rend pas forcément
compte à un moment donné que bah cette
image c'est pas c'est pas une véritable
photo que ce texte c'est pas un
véritable texte qui a été écrit à la
main par quelqu'un enfin voilà c'est
mais il faut en manipulations qui enfin
on voit bien maintenant avec des
imitations de VO de Ch comme ça on voit
tout un tas de choses aujourd'hui ce
qu'on appelle les deep fake les deep
fake aujourd'hui c'est c'est c'est de
l'image c'est de la voix et donc du
texte voilà c'est l'ensemble des des
trois technologie qui font que bah oui
on arrive sur des choses qui
aujourourd'hui sont assez difficilement
dcelables VO donc c'est pas c'est pas si
nouveau que ça non alors c'est pas si
nouveau que ça et ça a évolué ça a
évolué ben forcément au cours du temps
ce qui aujourd'hui fait que
l'intelligence artificielle reprend un
petit peu dans l'actualité c'est surtout
qu' aujourd'hui on produit énormément de
données et l'intelligence artificielle
ne vit que si la donnée existe
c'estàdire que c'est sur la base de
données qu'on sélectionne qu'on va être
capable de faire tourner un certain
nombre de moteurs ou d'intelligence pour
produire un résultat donc si vous avez
pas de données si a pas de données il y
a pas d'intelligence àici intelligence
artificielle ou alors elle est elle est
très très limitée donc c'est pour ça que
jusqu'à on va dire les années 2000 où on
produisait pas énormément de données ça
c'était quelque chose qui qui n'était
pas très très évolué dans dans dans les
systèmes d'information des entreprises
depuis les années on va dire 2010 on
commence à vooir une résurgence de cette
intelligence artificielle dans un
certain nombre de fonctions et
maintenant effectivement au niveau des
RH parce que bah parce qu'on se on s'est
rendu compte qu'il y a tout un tas de
choses qu'on peut automatiser qu'on peut
accélérer pour faciliter le travail des
RH et ce que je dis souvent c'est que
même si on fait appel à l'intelligence
artificielle moi je pense que ça
humanise encore plus la RH aujourd'hui
parce que ça les libère d'un certain
nombre de fonctions qui étit répétitive
et qui n'avait pas beaucoup de valeur
ajoutée et qui aujourd'hui bah leur
permet de se concentrer sur l'humain ce
qu'on ce qu'il faisait peut-être un
petit peu moins dans les dans les
grosses entreprises notamment où Ben
vous devez brasser tout un tas de
personnel ça commence avec le
recrutement la sélection des dossiers
par exemple al ça commence effectivement
dès le départ pour reprendre ce qui a
été dit ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure
par par Émilie il y a encore quelques
années on parlait beaucoup du parcours
employé parce qu'on s'intéressait à à la
vie de l'employé Dans dans l'entreprise
donc comment je l'accompagne depuis son
entrée jusqu'à le retenir déjà pendant
un certain nombre d'années et donc le
former donc le voilà l'amener à à rester
le plus longtemps possible aujourd'hui
on parle beaucoup du parcours candidat
et le parcours candidat c'est offrir à
un moment donné une expérience au
candidat qui va être la plus sympathique
possible pour donner une bonne image de
l'entreprise et c'est là où
effectivement intervient l'intelligence
artificielle c'est que bah si je donne
une une bonne image forcément je vais
attirer beaucoup de gens et donc il va
falloir que je sois capable de traiter
rapidement ces dossiers là pour pouvoir
répondre aussi très rapidement parce
qu'encore une fois on est sur
l'instantané c'estàd que si je réponds
si je postule à une offre aujourd'hui si
je suis une très grande entreprise et
que je reçois 1000 ou 2000 candidatures
par jour j'ai 3 4 jours pour répondre
sinon le candidat va zapper donc traiter
3 4000 dossiers par jour il va falloir à
un moment donné qu'il a quelque chose
qui MTE quoi oui c'est voilà si si on
est 15 sélectionné c'est
exactement voilà je va avoir besoin de
quelque chose qui m'aide et là c'est là
où je vais mettre en place effectivement
un certain nombre de règles qui vont
m'aider à sélectionner les bons dossiers
pour que ça matche avec lesah les
profils qui sont attendus dans
l'entreprise ça correspond à des
attentes que j'ai ça ça n'évitera pas
l'intelligence artificielle encore une
fois ça n'évitera pas le contact
physique qui est qu'à un moment donné
une fois que j'ai sélectionné le
candidat bah je vais le recevoir pour
savoir effectivement bah qui est cette
personne que j'ai en face de moi alors
il y a il y a il y a le recrutement il y
a l'accueil dans l'entreprise évidemment
là aussi ça peut ça peut exactement sur
l'accueil en entreprise parce que on va
ce que je parlais tout à l'heure c'est
queà partir du moment où on a passé le
cap du parcours candidat on va passer
dans le parcours employé et là l'idée
c'est aussi d'offrir un certain nombre
de services bah à mon employé et donc de
faciliter sur l'intégration de
l'entreprise donc c'est-à-dire enfin
pour prendre des exemples assez simples
automatiser la création des badges
l'obtention des ordinateurs les accès
les accès aux différents services dont
j'ai besoin les accès au répertoire de
partage d'information dont j'ai besoin
l'entreprise tous les trucs qui sont pas
les plus passionnants voilà tous les
trucs pas forcément les plus passion
l'entreprise mais qui doivent être fait
et que je vais pouvoir voilà et que je
vais pouvoir effectivement automatiser
et sur la base des profils que je
recrute B faire rentrer des gens alors
je suis d'utiliser ce ce ce terme là
mais de faire rentrer des gens dans des
cases pour un moment donné bah leur dire
bah cette personne là je vais lui
accorder tout tous ces toutes ces
chosesl dans l'entreprise au démarrage
de l'entreprise voilà ça effectivement
l'intelligence artificielle peut aider à
faire cette présélection la formation La
formation parce que sur la base
effectivement du parcours de mon de mon
candidat donc je l'ai recruté pour un
certain profil mais effectivement je
vais devoir l'accompagner par la suite
l'amener à à évoluer au sein de
l'entreprise donc je vais je vais devoir
détecter sur la base de son parcours et
des retours et des échanges qu'il a avec
son manager notamment quel est le
quelles sont les formations que je vais
pouvoir lui donner pour un soit
augmenter ses ses compétences soit
l'orienter vers peut-être autre chose
parce que je me rends compte que bah au
cours de son parcours cette personne
aspire à d'autres choses dans
l'entreprise et que je vais bah lui
trouver le meilleur parcours en
entreprise de formation voilà alors
euh donc on voit bien au fond c'est un
gain de temps c'est libération temp
c'est libération de temps pour les pour
les gens auourd pour les tch essentiel
au fond mais alors ce que vous disiez
parce que y il y a toujours un petit
mais évidemment làdedans c'est c'est en
effet il faut des données et donc il
faut protéger aussi ces données alors
c'est ça il y a deux il y a a y a
plusieurs éléments d'ailleurs c'est
c'est c'est l'objet de des discussions
qu'on a en ce
moment au niveau de l'Europe il y a tout
un tas de règlements qui se mettent en
place le plus connu on va dire de tout
le monde c'est le fameux rgpd donc le
règlement de protection des données qui
est lui supervisé par la cil et qui là
effectivement nous oblige à protéger les
données qu'on a en entreprise la
protection des données personnel en
entreprise mais aussi ailleurs c'est pas
que que l'entreprise et puis après vous
avez la sécurisation des données qui est
qu'une fois que j'ai mis en place un nom
de règles ben je vais les sécuriser
puisque qui dit données digitales dit
potentiellement diffusion
un peu partout et donc je dois
effectivement les sécuriser ces
informations là dans l'entreprise et là
il y a un autre un autre aspect c'est
c'est ENF un autre organisme on va dire
qui gère ça c'est l'an donc c'est la
c'est c'est l'organisme d'état qui
vérifie le contrôle le contrôle et la
sécurisation de ces données et puis
d'illeurs après vous avez tout un tas
d'autres articles au niveau européen qui
viennent un peu complexifier tout ça
donc vous avez notamment les les les loi
Nice 1 Nice 2 qui voilà qui qui qui
essaent de réguler la protection et la
sécurisation des données au sein de la
Communauté européenne donc avec des
entreprises qui sont plus ou moins
ciblées en fonction de leur secteur
d'activité et puis en France
actuellement et discuté à l'Assemblée
une loi qui s'appelle sen sur lequel
effectivement il y a desah il y a des
retocages réguliers parce que l'Europe
est pas forcément d'accord avec avec la
France sur un certain nombre de
dispositifs et de directives et voilà ça
crée beaucoup de ça crée beaucoup de de
de bruit autour de cette protection des
données parce que je pense effectivement
personnellement que c'est un véritable
enjeu que la protection et la
sécurisation des données entreprise mais
en Europe on a culturellement des pays
qui qui n'ont pas la même vision de la
protection de la données personnelle
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une donnée
personnelle comment je la protège
jusqu'où je la protège voilà tout le
monde a des des divergences làdessus
c'est vrai que unifier ça au niveau de
l'Europe c'est très compliqué et ça a
forcément des répercussions au niveau
national en France d'une façon générale
vous diriez voilà l'intelligence
artificielle c'est c'est c'est une aide
très forte dans dans dans les
RH oui et le le voilà et le le la
barrière c'est ça c'est la protection
des données enfin c'est exactement ça
c'est c'est à un moment donné une fois
que j'ai récolté de la donnée c'est
qu'est-ce que j'en fais de cette données
c'est comment je la sécurise comment je
la protège et comment alors j'ai des
données on va dire général sensibles qui
sont plutôt lié aux personnes qui sont
dans mon entreprise par exemple et puis
après j'ai des données plutôt métiers
que je dois aussi protéger parce que bah
on n'est pas à l'abri on n'est pas à
l'abri aujourd'hui de la la concurrence
de la compétition qui chercherait à
récolter des données de chez moi donc la
protection des données c'est un
véritable sujet et ça allait d'autant
plus effectivement qu'aujourd'hui bah
ces fameux moteurs d'intelligence
artificielle doivent brasser toutes ces
données sont souvent pas hébergés chez
dans l'entreprise mais sont hébergés
chez des fournisseurs de service
d'intelligence artificielle et ça veut
dire que je dois un moment donné
transposer mes données à l'extérieur de
mon entreprise et c'est là que se pose
le cas de à qui je les partage comment
je les partage qu'est-ce que je fais des
résultats qui sont qui sont trouvés
est-ce que je les partage est-ce que je
les conserve comment l'entreprise qui a
dével elopp ces intelligence
artificielle m'assure que ces données ne
sont pas diffusées à l'extérieur et que
les résultats ne sont diffusés qu'au
sein deentreprise c'est un véritable
enjeu pour toutes les entreprises au et
ça ça évidemment ça demande une
formation nouvelle pour pour les pour
les des Raches notamment oui sur tous
les sous-domaines de la fonction par
exemple on parlait de recrutement tout à
l'heure donc effectivement on va faire
appel par exemple à un ATS pour gérer
les candidatures donc là c'est
effectivement être beaucoup plus agile
sur les nouvelles technologies dédiées
au ressources humaines on parle on peut
parler aussi par exemple du socle
l'administratif on parle de la paye
voilà donc c'est pareil aussi des le SH
B le oui la pay ça voilà effectivement
on parle de de paye en mode SAS par
exemple là par rapport au SIRH c'est
vrai que effectivement ça devient même
une fonction indispensable pour des
grands groupes he de donc on parle de RH
manager par exemple donc là c'est
vraiment une fonction clé au sein de
l'entreprise pour pouvoir on va dire bah
aider le DRH dans sa fonction au
quotidien et il y a des il y a des
organismes de formation il y a des
vousmême vous enfin l'association vous
vous aidez les Lesh à trouver des oui
effectivement il y a des des formations
dans ce domaine euh des entreprises
aussi je pense le le fond mais oui
oui oui mais c'est c'est vrai que c'est
non mais c'est c'est tellement un métier
enfin je veux dire le domaine est
tellement é
ça évolue s arrê voilà et ça évolue de
plus en plus V ouais ça évolue de plus
en plus vite ou non c'est vrai doit être
adaptable adaptable vous savez ce que
c'est ouais vous le vivez au quotidien
c'est ça en tout cas c'est des problèmes
passionnant et c'est passionnant parce
que de de les remettre dans le dans le
dans le prisme des DH parce que ça on
fait des problèmes humains enfin avant
tout hein c'est c'est au fond c'est
c'est c'est le fond des c'est le fond
des choses merci beaucoup merci à tous
et puis B on reprendra avec grand
plaisir ces débats hein merci et donc je
rappelleah la D non la
ndrh ndrh a il y a un site il y a un
site Internet nous avons notre page
LinkedIn
voilà beaucoup d'événements que vous
organisez exactement le prochain est le
6 décembre donc c'est une soirée bah de
fin d'année et après nous retrouvons au
mois de janvier sur l'actualité sociale
et également sur un événement sur la
qualité de vie au travail le le 30
janvier mardi 30 janvier vers 18h 30
janvier donc bah allez allez donc nous
communiquerons effectivement sur notre
page LinkedIn j'invite tous les les DRH
membres et non membres et non membres
voilà de venir de nous rejoindre et de
consulter notre page voilà ok merci
beaucoup merci à
tousp
[Musique]